wir wollen deswegen jetzt einmal die
Frage stellen ob die AFD denn wirklich
verboten werden könnte und darüber er
ist mir jetzt schon zugeschaltet kann
ich jetzt sprechen mit dem
Rechtswissenschaftler Professor
Christian waltoff von der humbal
Universität Berlin der das möchte ich
gerne noch ergänzend ergänzend
vorstellen 2013 im Auftrag des
Bundesrates für ein NPD Verbotsverfahren
vor das Bundesverfassungsgericht gezogen
ist guten Abend nach Berlin guten Abend
Herr waltorf ihre Antragsschrift damals
2003 die sie zusammen mit Professor
Christoph Möller verfasst haben war rund
250 Seiten stark das geht also um es mal
salop zu sagen nicht einfach so so ein
Parteiverbotsverfahren was braucht es
damit ein solches Verfahren eröffnet
werden kann das imppd Verbotsverfahren
war damals sehr gut vorbereitet durch
die Nachrichtendienste des Bundesamt und
die Landesämter für Verfassungsschutz
und die hatten uns über 3000
Belegstellen 3000 Beweisstücke zur
Verfügung gestellt als Tatsachenbasis
für ein solches Verfahren
das heißt wenn man über ein AFD
Verfahren jetzt nachdenkt und die
Chancen ob das Erfolg haben könnte
bräuchte man erstmal eine
Materialsammlung der Verfassungsschützer
mhm bevor wir gleich auf dieses mögliche
Verfahren schauen vielleicht noch einmal
auf das NPD Verbotsverfahren warum hatte
das kein
Erfolg in einer potierten
Kurzzusammenfassung des Urteils von 2017
würde ich sagen das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat klar gesagt
das ist eine Nazipartei die echt
verfassungsfeindlich die
rechtsextremistisch ist und unsere
Ordnung beseitigen will sie ist aber so
unbedeutend dass wir sie nicht verbieten
möchten also inhaltlich gab es gar kein
Problem bei der NPD
aber es ist halt eine sehr kleine Partei
die auch immer schwächer geworden ist
und das Gericht hat dann ein neues
Kriterium die Potentialität eingeführt
die so im Grundgesetz gar nicht drin
steht und gesagt die Partei ist so
unbedeutend dass wir sie nicht verbieten
wollen welche Unterschiede sehen Sie
denn zwischen dem Verfahren damals und
einem möglichen AFD
Parteiverbotsverfahren ein ganz
zentraler Unterschied ist dass das
Parteiprogramm der NPD das ist auch
heute noch dasjenige von 2012
ähm eindeutig diese völkische Grundlinie
in allen politischen Aussagen zum
Ausdruck bringt also viele Passagen des
NPD Parteiprogramms lesen sich wie das
nsdp Parteiprogramm von 1920 ich habe
mir heute Nachmittag noch mal das
Parteiprogramm der AFD angeschaut das
ist nicht
rechtsextremistisch das enthält auch
nicht die Aussagen die jetzt vom
Korrektiv aufgedeckt wurden das enthält
sogar in Passagen Bekenntnisse zum
Grundgesetz man kann jetzt sagen das ist
nur vorgetäuscht oder so etwas aber das
Parteiprogramm das im NPD Verfahren ganz
wichtig war für die Zurechnung dessen
was die Partei macht ähm das hätte man
bei der AFD nicht mhm wir bekommen dazu
die ganze Zeit auch Fragen bei Youtube
und eine Frage die natürlich viele
interessiert ist Bruno schneeh hat hat
sie uns gestellt wie wahrscheinlich wäre
denn so ein Verbotsverfahren hätte
dieses Erfolg und was wäre wenn es
scheitern würde wie gesagt eine seriöse
Abschätzung über die Erfolgschancen
könnte man nur machen wenn man Material
hätte allein das was jetzt dieses
recherchenetzwerk Korrektiv aufgedeckt
hat das würde nicht reichen das muss ja
auch der Partei erstmal zugerechnet
werden das war ja keine
Parteiveranstaltung dass da jetzt
hochrangige Parteifunktionäre waren geht
schon mal in die Richtung einer
möglichen Zurechnung aber alleine würde
das nicht reichen das heißt man bräuchte
eine ähnlich umfangreiche
Materialsammlung von den
Nachrichtendiensten von den
inlandsgeheimdiensten die flächendeckend
recherchieren
äh wie ist das Potenzial ist das der
normale Zustand der AFD oder ist das ein
Ausreißer dann könnte man eine seriöse
Abschätzung machen ob ein Verfahren
vielleicht Erfolg haben würde und ich
würde auch noch darauf hinweisen wollen
dass das Verbotsverfahren 4er Jahre
gedauert hat ab Antragstellung ab
politischen Beschlusses durch
durchzuführen sogar 5 Jahre das heißt
ein Schnellschuss mit dem man jetzt
irgendwie politische Konkurrenten
vielleicht aus den Landtagswahlen im
Herbst heraushalten könnte wäre das ganz
sicher nicht damit haben Sie schon eine
Frage beantwortet die wir gerade
bekommen haben die nämlich auch in die
Richtung gegen wie lange würde das
dauern bis zur nächsten Bundestagswahl
wäre das sie haben jetzt die
Landtagswahl angesprochen aber bis zur
nächsten Bundestagswahl wäre das ja wenn
wir ihn jetzt richtig zuhören auch
niemals durch uns fragt noch jemand und
zwar ick be Youtube wäre ein AFD
Verbotsverfahren nicht trotz geringer
Erfolgswahrscheinlichkeit moralisch
richtig wie würden sie das Bewerten das
ist natürlich ein legitimer Einwand aber
wenn es bei der NPD war es nicht so
schlimm dass sie nicht verboten wurde
weil ja gesagt wurde die Programmatik
und die Aktivitäten der Partei sind klar
verfassungsfeindlich das heißt es gab
kein Gütesiegel in Anführungszeichen des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts dass diese
Partei für unbedenklich erklärt hat sie
war halt nur zu unbedeutend man wollte
sie nicht verbieten wenn aber bei einem
AFD Verbotsverfahren rauskommen würde
das reicht nicht für die
Verfassungswidrigkeit auf die
Gesamtpartei bezogen dann wäre das ja
eine Art Gütesiegel aus Karlsruhe dass
diese Partei doch nicht so schlimm ist
und das wäre natürlich fatal das einzige
was bei der AFD sicher ist dass sie
nicht zu unbedeutend ist um
gegebenenfalls verboten werden zu können
denn Potenzialität besitzt sie ja
leider sie haben den Verfassungsschutz
auch schon angesprochen den
Inlandsgeheimdienst der beobachtet die
AF D schon seit einiger Zeit wir haben
da einmal eine Übersicht vorbereitet in
die wir einmal gemeinsam reinschauen
können im März 2022 hat das Bundesamt
für für Verfassungsschutz die bundesafd
als rechtsextremistischen Verdachtsfall
eingestuft schon ein Jahr zuvor im März
2021 wurde der AFD Landesverband in
Thüringen vom dortigen
landesverfassungsschutz als gesichert
rechtsextrem eingestuft der
landesverfassungsschutz in Sachsen
Anhalt bewertet den dortigen AFD Land
esverband seit November 2023 ebenfalls
als gesichert rechtsextrem und seit
dezember
2023 gilt das gleiche auch für die AFD
in
Sachsen welche Rolle spielen diese
Einstufung denn überhaupt diese
Einstufungen haben zur Folge dass der
Verfassungsschutz überhaupt aktiv werden
kann und beobachten darf und das ist ja
erstmal die erste Grundvoraussetzung für
ein mögliches für ein potenzielles
Verbotsverfahren aber man muss bedenken
dass das gesichert rechtsextrem oder
rechtsextremistischer Verdachtsfall das
sind die juristischen Kriterien damit
der Verfassungsschutz aktiv werden kann
damit vupersonen eingeschleustt werden
können oder solche Sachen damit die
Material sammeln können die beobachten
können das ist aber nicht der Maßstab
für ein Parteiverbot für ein
Parteiverbot müsste sehr viel mehr
hinzukommen wie würde sie wir haben es
jetzt in diesem Stream schon immer
wieder ein bisschen besprochen aber
vielleicht können Sie uns die einzelnen
Schritte noch mal darlegen also wie
würde ein solches Partei
Verbotsverfahren ablaufen mit welchen
Konsequenzen sie haben jetzt gerade die
V Leute z.B auch angesprochen die können
ihre Arbeit ja nicht einfach so
weitermachen richtig genau also erstmal
müsste man Antragsteller finden das kann
die Bundesregierung der Bundestag oder
der Bundesrat sein also man bräuchte
eine Mehrheit jeweils die den Antrag in
Karlsruhe stellt und sobald der
politische Beschluss gefasst ist also
auch noch vor Einreichung einer
Antragsschrift müssen alle
geheimdienstlichen alle
nachrichtendienstlichen Tätigkeiten
abgestellt werden also wenn man etwa
versonen in den Vorständen etwa in
Thüringen oder in Sachsen
haben sollte was wir ja natürlich nicht
wissen dann müssten Sie von diesem Tag
an wie man so schön sagt abgeschaltet
werden also jeder Kontakt müsste
unterbunden werden und es hätte zur
Folge dass während des Verbotsverfahrens
keine validen nachrichtendienstlichen
Informationen aus dem Inneren der Partei
mehr bekannt werden
würden wel wel sie haben es gerade auch
schon angesprochen für dieses konkrete
mögliche Verbotsverfahren sehen sie
jetzt erstmal ja keine keine Auswirkung
durch dieses Treffen in pozdam trotzdem
so würde ich es nicht sagen also wenn
das ein ein Modell flächendeckend wäre
wenn man nachweisen könnte dass die
Partei so denkt und dass das die echten
politischen Ziele wären dann wäre das
schon relevant aber dass eben zwei
hochrangige funktioniier noch einige
andere Leute als nicht
Parteiveranstaltung da teilgenommen ist
ist natürlich bedrückend und schlimm
äh und überhaupt nicht in keiner Weise
zu rechtfertigen aber es müsste noch
mehr kommen man müsste viel mehr
flächendeckende Informationen haben um
das Risiko abschätzen zu können okay
eine Frage die ich doch gerne an Sie
weitergeben würde wäre es denn denkbar
die Frage an den an den
Rechtswissenschaftler dass man einzelne
Personen wie z.B Björn höcke mit
rechtlichen Mitteln eben
ausschließt also grundsätzlich gibt es
ein sogenanntes Parteienprivileg das
heißt eine Partei die eine politische
Partei die nicht verboten ist darf auch
gar nicht benachteiligt werden nur das
Bundesverfassungsgericht kann das
feststellen aber es gibt im Grundgesetz
eine bisher auch noch gar nicht genutzte
Möglichkeit in diesem Konzept whrhafter
Demokratie dass nämlich auch einzelne
Bürgerinnen und Bürger äh an ihrer
grundrechtsausübung gehindert werden
können das nennt man Verwirkung der
Grundrechte Artikel 18 unseres
Grundgesetzes und da wir jetzt das
Problem dass man damit das Parteiverbot
dass man nicht erreicht oder nicht
erzielen will jetzt nicht umgehen darf
so als Parteiverbot des kleinen Mannes
aber theoretisch können extremistische
Bürger die ihre Meinungsfreiheit und
ihre politischen Grundrechte gegen im
Kampf gegen das Grundgesetz ein setzen
denen kann dieser Grundrechtsschutz
entzogen werden davon wurde noch nie in
der Geschichte der Bundesrepublik
Gebrauch gemacht Herr Professor waltof
dann gerne abschließend noch einmal wir
haben jetzt viel darüber gesprochen es
wird in diesen Tagen wie gesagt jetzt
auch wieder verstärkt diskutiert ein
mögliches Parteiverbotsverfahren für die
AFD sollte man sollte weiter darüber
nachgedacht werden oder würden Sie auf
Grundlage ihrer Erfahrung davon abraten
das ja in Gang zu bringen nein ich würde
auf jeden Fall drüber nachdenken und die
entsprechenden politischen Instanzen die
das gegebenenfalls ja in Gang setzen
könnten müssen sich rückv bei ihren
Sicherheitsbehörden wie die Lage ist und
wie gesagt ohne dass man diese
gesicherten Informationen hat kann man
auch nicht abschätzen ob das
erfolgversprechend und damit sinnvoll
ist sagt Professor Christian waltorf
Rechtswissenschaftler an der humbald
Universitäts Berlin vielen Dank für Ihre
Zeit und für das Gespräch